on a vu ici au tertiaire une mer chaude
à 28 degrés alors une version qui se
retire
c'est une forêt tropicale qui va se
développer sur le sud du rocher
cocotiers palier en grâce c'était la
végétation du moment en fait c'est une
forêt tropicale qui est à l'origine de
la formation
il n'est pas historien il n'est pas
paléontologue et pourtant jérôme
philippot n'est pas seulement leurs
propriétaires des grottes de foulon avec
le temps il est devenu un formidable
conteur un passeur de mémoire
en pénétrant dans les entrailles de ces
grottes c'est en voyage à travers le
temps qui attend le puck rôti nos têtes
on a beaucoup de pierres ce ne sont pas
de simples pierres les pierres voire
duflot canton les ovales brille à
l'intérieur
la sq on a deux bleus ça s'appelle de la
calcédoine ces semi précieux ont fait
des bijoux avec un saint mais sa
cheminée elle pour les messieurs
pédagogue il interpelle le public test
ses connaissances titille la curiosité
des enfants
la concentration jadco nazis des
centaines de milliers à ce jour personne
ne se l'expliqu ait ni les
paléontologues ni les géologues à
l'intérieur des grottes
la température est constante 12 degrés
avec un taux d'humidité à 90 % en une
heure c'est 60 millions d'années qui
défile sous nos cieux
résistant ancien fond de mer est en fait
c'est un milieu qui est très très riche
en histoire en géologie et cesti sur la
con raconte en fait on raconte toutes
sortes des grottes on d'identifier dans
ça comporte six qu'on poursuit depuis
publié en or jusqu'aujourd'hui endroit
unique au monde
et donc c'était vraiment chouette de
découvrir l'intérieur il ya énormément
de choses à voir avec près de 45000
visiteurs par an les grottes de foule on
reste une visite culturelle sur les
adultes comme les enfants adorent les
histoires qui les font rêver